people linked by destiny will always find
each other.
Who's Yennefer?
welcome back everyone is Charlie toss a
coin to your Witcher this is going to be my
season two top 10 predictions video so
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos I will
be doing bonus videos for The Witcher
while we wait for episodes to come back
we already have a loose timeline for
when that's going to be so don't worry
I'll break it down to the video but
obviously spoiler warning for everything
from The Witcher Season 1 if you haven't
seen the episodes yet so starting with
number 10 the season 2 timeline will be
way more linear and even though all
three of the main leads Geralt ciri and
yennefer won't always be together at the
same time for the most part all the
storylines will be happening during the
same time period I think this comes as a
relief to most of you guys because on
the videos that I posted for The Witcher
Season one there was a lot of confusion
about where everybody was in the
timeline in any given episode they'll
probably a couple more flashbacks just
for context because there's still some
things that happen in the past that we
don't have any answers about yet like
what happened to series parents Duney
and pavetta they're lost at sea we need
to get a flashback to kind of explain
that maybe towards the end of season 2
this season you all probably noticed
that the timelines were different for
each character though so series started
in present-day Geralt started a couple
years before she was born
and then Janna first timeline started a
couple of decades before that if it
wasn't clear even though the actress
that plays yennefer looks younger than
Henry Cavill in real life in the context
of the story yennefer of vengerberg is a
couple decades older than Geralt of
Rivia both mages and witcher's age much
slower than normal humans so Geralt is
around his 70s during the course of this
season
yennefer is around her 90s when they
meet for the first time in the books
really only follow the characters until
ciri is in her 20s so there's not a ton
of huge time jumps between the first
book in the last book because right now
ciri is supposed to be around 13 years
old if you play the games though the
games are meant to be a sequel to the
book story so the characters are all a
couple years older in the present day of
the video games but there are a lot of
flashbacks during the video games to
either
the showrunner has already confirmed
that the season 2 timeline will make way
more sense and be way easier to follow
number 9 talking about what's happening
at the beginning of the season since the
TV show already changed the way the
Geralt meets ciri and on the show this
peasant family lives right next to
sodden hill where that big battle was
going on the next big thing that they'll
probably do as Geralt told the man who
saved him is travel through sodden hill
to get to care morhen in the school of
the wolf
that's where vesemir is where Garret was
raised and trained to be a Witcher if
you haven't read the books or you
haven't played the games there are
several different schools for witcher's
the school of the wolf is just one of
them initially he wanted to go there
because he was slowly dying from his
wounds but because he just found ciri
his child of surprise and the person
he's charged to protect it just makes
sense to go to care morhen because it's
way safer there
number 8 on the way through sodden hill
- also probably try to find yennefer
there were a couple of reasons why ciri
said who's in affair when they met in
the woods
even though ciri herself has never heard
yennefer of vengerberg name spoken out
loud she probably didn't even know she
existed - the last few episodes the
reason why she says her name though is
one probably because of her elder blood
powerful magic giving her visions and
dreams that she doesn't totally
understand in the books series crazy
powers give her really dark dreams so
she's probably thinking to herself why
do I keep hearing this name yennefer in
my head and in my dreams who is this
person that I keep thinking about and to
the more practical reason for sending
them through sodden Hill on their way to
the school of the wolf is for story
progression it allows Geralt to try and
find out whether or not yennefer was
killed during the battle because
yennefer geralt and ciri probably won't
all be together for a good long while
most of Geralt story for the first half
of season 2 will probably just be him in
ciri together
Papa bless but number 7 because we are
going to the school the wolf will
probably meet vesemir for the first time
on the show we didn't see his character
during season 1 because the closest we
got there was when we saw the flashbacks
of Geralt smother Vicente leaving him at
their doorstep so to speak if you've
been on Twitter the last couple of days
- you probably saw Mark Hamill was
tweeting about it ever since they
announced Netflix was doing a Witcher
series people were tweeting at Mark
Hamill that he should be vesemir he's
never read The Witcher books never
played the games so he has no idea what
the Witcher story is or who
here is but as you can see he's totally
down to play him even the showrunner
Lauren hiss rich made it seem like she
was going to reach out to him so if his
schedule works out with their shooting
days for season 2 which is sometime next
spring we could totally see mark hamill
vesemir if you're not familiar with the
character vesemir is just a much older
Witcher who taught Geralt and helps
teach ciri in the books so he's sort of
soft retired from regular Witcher
monster hunting duties and spends most
of his time at the school the wolf is an
instructor speaking of which number six
big one ciri will probably begin training to
become a Witcher herself pretty soon
they changed the reason why Geralt chose
her as his child of surprise from the
books on the TV show they made it seem
like more of a coincidence like okay
I'll do the same thing that you did and
choose the law of surprise and then he
finds out that they're pregnant but in
the books Geralt knows that series
mother pavetta is pregnant before he
chooses the law of surprise and in the
books his hope was that it would be a
boy so that he could train that boy to
become another Witcher because in the
present-day of the books The Witcher
order is slowly dying out there was that
line of dialogue earlier in the season
from yennefer where she says there's so
few wishers left in the world why do I
keep running into you all of a sudden
the reason why their order is slowly
dying out is because so few children
survive the trials that they go through
to become witcher's they go the trial
the grasses they take a bunch of potions
that give them their Witcher mutations
with their special powers
most kids wind up dying during that so
it's just a simple math equation you
have fewer new witchers being minted and
older ones dying off or being killed
quicker and quicker so it's just rapidly
shrinking their order around the world
and even though they haven't really
talked about it part of Geralt implied duty to the
school of the wolf as a Witcher is to
help create more witcher's to sustain
the order so even though ciri is born a
girl his goal is still the same he needs
to create more witcher's so because ciri
belongs to him as child a surprise and
he has no use for an actual child his
main goal is basically just to create a
new witcher like okay here you go
so even though his goals are very simple
all the ciri elder blood stuff the
nilfgaard war emperor Emhyr just makes
things way more complicated for him and
you also notice in those flashbacks that
Geralt is about the same age as ciri
when his mother
drops him off at the school of the wolf
so Ciri is of a proper age to begin
training if you've ever played the games
- you see Ciri training in a flashback
scene at the very beginning of Witcher 3
number five series elder blood is going to
continue to manifest itself in more
weird ways freaking out Geralt & vesemir
we've already seen her use her abilities
without trying just completely hook out
on these brigands she has no control
over them she doesn't know anything
about her special bloodline so they'll
need someone like yennefer or Tris or
another mage to explain how serious
powers work what it all means and why
she's even more important now than she
was before
because you have to remember that even
without the elder blood and the special
magical powers ciri is already a really
important person because she's the
rightful heir to the throne of Cintra
and through her grandmother's marriage
to this guy to the Skellig and that's
not even the end of it through her
father Duney she's also heir to a much
larger territory which we can't really
talk about without getting into spoilers
so if you have read the books or played
the games please do not post spoilers
for series father due knee number 4
since yennefer took off after the Battle
of sodden Hill she probably won't be
around to help Geralt with ciri probably
at least until the middle or near the
end of season 2 depending on how fast
they move through the timeline but
univer is the most qualified person to
help train ciri in magic because she is
one of the most powerful magical people
on the show she just doesn't understand
how her powers work most of this
probably won't happen till after garel
realizes what's going on with ciri
because he's only just met her here he
hasn't seen her use any of her powers or
anything like that and no one's told him
about her special powers
he's very learned is a Witcher but he
only has rudimentary knowledge of magic
like he can cast all those signs that
you saw during the season like this is
the art side the one that he uses during
the Butcher of lava can fight when he
blasts them back with his telekinetic
force there's the Ignace sign the Quinn
the AXI the eared ensigns but that's
pretty much the extent of his magical
knowledge so that's why you need someone
like yennefer trysts to come in and
teach ciri actual magic number three
will probably meet emperor Emhyr
officially in nilfgaard for the first
time we've only heard about him on the
show so far but if you've read the books
please don't post spoilers about emperor
Emhyr he's the one who ordered
the attack on sodden Hill he's the one
that frin Gila keeps referring to as the
white flame quote unquote in the last
few episodes he out stood the usurper
from his throne and he's been reforming
nofe Guardian politics and cleaning
house since retaking his throne the last
couple of years he's also the one who
ordered Kay here this character here to
bring ciri to him at the beginning of
the season when you think about all the
stuff he's responsible for this season
he does kind of come off like a villain
but he does have a good reason for doing
what he's doing that we might not find
out about till a little bit later but
because it's meant to play like a big
reveal like I said please no spoilers
about Emperor Emhyr in the comments
number two we'll learn more about the
mage Vilgefortz who we saw in the
final few episodes of season 1 he seemed
like he was fighting against nilfgaard
on the side of the brotherhood of
sorcerers they kept referring to how
battle hungry who was and how much time
he'd spent making war he had that big
fight with Kay here even though he lost
I know a lot of people were upset about
that because vulgur forts is way more
powerful than that in the books he would
have never lost to Kay here but he seems
like he's a good character fighting for
the Brotherhood but then there's this
last scene with him that we saw in the
finale that's super important because
like he said supposed to be fighting to
defeat nilfgaard then why does he
brutally take one of his fellow mages
from the Brotherhood when he asked for
his help if it wasn't clear Vilgefortz is killing one of the good guys
here that's why you see all these other
dead nilfgaardian soldiers around him
help me bro they just bludgeons him to
death there's a very important reason
why he's probably doing that and why it
seems like he may have flipped sides
during the battle but maybe wants to get
rid of the Brotherhood like think about
the other mage they came for yennefer as
a saboteur within their ranks while she
was on the tower we'll learn more about
what's going on with him next season but
he's a hugely important character in the
books in number one finally we also
learn how all these disparate events
during season 1 are connected in how
ciri is at the center of everything the
disappearance of her mother and father
Duney and pavetta the fall of sintra
the nilfgaardian wars the battle of
sodden hill Vilgefortz, Emperor
Emhyr the dryads and the elder blood it's
all connected and ciri is at the center
of everything the showrunner said that
they had about a seven season plan I'm
expecting them to make it to at least
four or five so I don't think that
they're going to reveal all these
things and how everything is connected
by the end of season 2 so please don't
post spoilers if you have read the books
or played the games if you want to find
answers to all those questions though
you can read the books and play the
games while you wait for season 2 to get
here it's all in there
the games don't cover everything from
the books they're kind of meant to be a
sequel to the book story but they do
have a bunch of flashbacks and big
reveals about stuff that happened during
the books the games are just really cool
either way they're just really badass
games right now the season 2 release
date won't be until 2021 but I'm
assuming it'll be summer 2021 or later
because the Game of Thrones prequel
series will probably release in spring
2021 and I don't think that Netflix
wants the witcher to have to compete
with that so expect them to plan around
the Game of Thrones prequel which will
probably run from April to June I'll
keep doing bonus videos through the next
week or so so leave all your video
requests and big questions and
predictions for season 2 on the video
everyone click here for all my Witcher
Netflix episode videos and Easter eggs
and click here for my Mandalorian season 2 teaser video
and Easter eggs thank you
so much for watching everybody toss a
coin to your Witcher!